boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are still at Indy bio demo day number
eight we are not gonna be talking to
Marcel Frankel from Gavilan Biodesign
yes thanks for coming on it
Marcel teach us about what you were just
giving your talk about well so drug
design today is a extremely challenging
field because even when we design great
drugs right even when we design drugs
that work the problem is that over time
either cancer or infectious diseases
they learn to become resistant to that
therapy right you you might have heard
of the superbugs right and in cancer you
always hear about cancer coming back
right so what happens is that this is
called your ability of the response
right so when we talk about is durable
response of the drug and the problem is
that it's extremely difficult to make
drugs that are durable and the reason
for that is that then there are numerous
ways how a pathogen can develop
resistance at Gavilan what we do as we
develop drugs that can play a chess
match and chess match can see what moves
right what mutations the pathogen or
cancer can do and design a drug that can
overcome those so it's really about
being able to design drugs in the fourth
I mentioned right being able to play a
chess game through time and that really
makes a huge difference on how good and
how impactful these drugs can be in
people's lives and what we're focused on
is in designing better drugs right and
so so that's what I was talking about
there
the other main problem of drug design is
that sometimes the biology tell us tells
us that we should go after a certain
target right there's something in the
system but that's what you really need a
hit if you want to make a difference
unfortunately it's normally extremely
difficult to hit those targets so what
we're making is a technology that can
really allows us to hit what we want not
what we can and hopefully by doing these
two things will change the paradigm of
drug design make better therapeutics and
finally start carrying some of these
diseases and so then let's let's walk us
through example so usually there's like
Pat pathogens or cancers are there like
you're giving us this example they're
running through permutations of ways for
them to succeed with what their yes
engine is and then to be able to figure
out how the body tries to watch and
tackle it s so it's kind of like you
said there's a game going on yeah
there's exactly right you know so the
truth does this what you're finding in
the end is evolution right there's that
saying life finds a way right so what a
drug is is a selective pressure in an
environment right you're selecting
against things that are susceptible to
the drug right so you're creating a
enhancefitness for the organisms that
are immune to that drug and they select
that population so what we need to do is
we need to be able to see what those
possible selection mechanisms are what
those mutations are and design a drug
not only against the target today but
against all possible variations of that
target and that's what we use our you
know unique proprietary and silicon
technology to do so you know and what we
hope to do is that that's really gonna
have an impact in people's lives and do
you take it then the pathogen or cancer
you take that into a into a into an
environment outside of the body and then
you observe the way that it's trying to
permutate and make advances and
encounter those no so this is really
cool it's all done computational all
computation how come you can simulate a
cancer or a pathogen that's trying to
make moves yes we do this at the
molecular level at the molecular yeah
and so so that's why we you know we've
spent the last 15 years of Duke build in
this technology and
you know we finally decide that a stunt
spin that out into a company and really
go ahead and use the technology to have
impact in people's lives and you know I
think this comes from our personal
experience with these diseases and you
know losing loved ones and really
wanting to do something about that you
know just I have a you know for me it
was my mom she got pancreatic cancer and
at first the drugs worked and then they
stopped working and we went to five
different doctors and we you know said
hey what can we do and the answer was
look the disease has progressed that's
where they used there's nothing we can
do about it you know and it was like no
right that's an unacceptable reality
that's not the world we want to live in
so unfortunately for my mom there was
nothing we could do but I think what
everyone in the goblin team is trying to
do is make it so that you know for the
people today and tomorrow
that that scenario changes and take us
into the environments where you're
actually able to do this to simulate
this because this happens does so many
of our but you said of our loved ones
that would love to pass more time with
let them be more creative let them
flourish more experience more of
Civilizations progress over time all
this great stuff and then okay when you
bring this into this to the simulation
environment then you're doing this at a
molecular level and how would it I mean
this is sound so you know let's try and
make this like as explain like I'm five
as possible okay you have this pathogen
in the environment and you're and you're
figuring out its moves and then figuring
out how we can do some what within the
body that yeah so you know think about
we really think about these things
called proteins right and the proteins
are kind of the workhorses in your body
they're the the things inside of you
that do the work so that you can live
right there are these almost tiny
machines there these biologic machines
you and normally when you're developing
a drug you're hitting one of those right
because there are the ones that do the
work to allow you to live hitting them
modulates that environment right
modulates that work so that's how you
can change the environment and change
you know treat a disease or you know
help somebody that has some condition
right you change that by messing with
these micro robots these biological
microrobots once we find the one that
we're targeting what we initiate really
is something almost like a chess game
you know in a chess game if you're gonna
play well you've got to be able to see
multiple moves ahead mm-hmm right and
when you're planning your next move you
you have that context that you're using
to make your decision yes this is
incredibly more complex because it's
multi-dimensional right it's not just
you have a few right so but it's pretty
similar and what we're doing right
you're looking at what are the fitness
conditions of the protein how does it do
its job how can it maintain its jobs
what possible variations of that shape
can adopt and how can a drug deal with
all of that right and those are the
answers that you ask and you really
require very sophisticated algorithms to
answer and that's what it's all about
and it's so then is it the protein
that's within the pathogen that you are
observing its evolution and trying to
see which moves it's trying to make and
then the and then you're trying to
design the drug that would then compete
against that the evolution of that
protein Tura interrupt whatever function
or you know sometimes you're enhancing
it first on there at times you're
shutting it off right there's multiple
ways to deal to try and modulate that in
that environment but what you're
ultimately doing is if it's a pathogen
you want to stop it in this tracks if
it's cancer you want to stop it and kill
it
you know and if it's another condition
then it's more you know sometimes you
want to increase something or decrease
something right you can think about out
immune diseases regulates the body's
immune system there you don't want to
kill anything you just want to you know
calm things down
all of these can be modulated by
designing better drugs and you know
that's really what we want to do it's
not only about toxicity right we
actually wanna design drugs that are
gonna help people right make people
healthier and live longer and you know
especially I was just telling it for us
it's about making sure that people are
really having better lives and not
losing loved ones to these diseases
right you know cancer is almost like the
boogeyman right when you're young you
believe in the boogeyman once you start
getting older the bogeyman changes its
name right every time that you feel a
lump that wasn't there in the back of
your mind you're like well you know
maybe it's something that shouldn't be
there right and if you have experience
with it you know that sometimes it's
like that one day you're fine and one
day you're not fine or someone you love
has do that so having something that can
treat that that can overcome that that's
really all we're about yeah I'm so
fascinated with the simulation
environment of analyzing the the
proteins evolutionary trajectory and how
its China have its what it wants to
achieve done within the body and how you
can then simulate the drug the so you're
simulating molecules that are then
competing against then you're also
trying to deliver it directly to where
that protein is for it to get either
inhibited or yep to have to enhance
something that competes against it yeah
exactly it's so freaking cool thank you
yes I believe a lot of why we called the
show simulation is because of really
cool things like this like all these
different aspects to these biological
simulations that I mean in many ways
like that civilization and the universe
could be similarly within our bodies we
can recreate these simulation
environments to see how we can tackle
pathogens without even doing it outside
like taking you having to do it outside
of the body but actually just simulated
it yeah now you know we do eventually
take these and test them right because
still today right no simulation is
perfect but the idea is
to get to a point where you know
whatever you're predicting is coming
true and the most exciting thing the
thing that really took us from being
academics to being here and you know is
that idea that you know we're almost
there right we're starting to see these
things so I'm actually still academic
finishing my PhD right now but you know
we're starting to see those results or
what we predict is what's coming true
when we test it and when you start
seeing that it starts giving a lot of
confidence that you can actually change
people's lives and that's that's what
it's all about right about bring about
change and then you guys give make the
simulations better and better make the
the drugs compete better and better and
then the idea is to deploy one to come
to actually for the physical use of you
yeah exactly and which one would that be
to compete against do you guys have any
so we work in two different ways
one a way is that we work through
partnerships where normally a partner
already has an initial molecule that
he's trying to optimize and we help them
optimize that I said okay the other one
is we have our own pipeline okay in
their own pipeline we're using our
unique ability to design custom and
ideal drugs to target drugs that other
people can't and there's a whole class
of proteins called
undruggable undruggable yeah and and
they're kind of like you know sometimes
called the holy grail medicine because
we know that they're important we've
validated you know using things like
CRISPR assays and we validated that they
matter and yet we haven't been able to
hit at them because they've remained in
trouble thus the name right they've
they've been resilient to other methods
so what we wish to do is show that we
can hit them and by doing so that would
really change medicine and will change
what we can do for the first time we
want to be able to hit what we can we
would be able to hit what we want and
that's gonna really make you know bring
in a new age of
medicine so we're very excited for that
okay okay cool it seems like yeah the
trajectory is yeah both having the
organizations that are currently trying
to figure out how to better deploy their
own drugs and then working with them
computationally and also on the with
your own pipeline that likes to make and
you think it the pathogens to compete
against our which ones for you guys
first II so you know personally we're
starting pancreatic cancer angry at ik
exactly right as I told you this is you
know a decision made from personal
reasons right the you know as I told you
the story about my mom you know there's
a little bit of you know you could call
it avenging going on right there's this
idea that we saw how terrible that
disease is and you know I don't think I
think it's terrible that anybody has to
go through that right so we want to
start there but we're gonna expand and
with partners we're doing both
infectious diseases like the superbugs
as well as cancers so going both ways
okay and then the for a company
trajectory then for people that are
wanting to work with you what are you
guys looking for right now so right now
we you know we're very fast so it takes
us about three weeks to go from the
beginning of a project to the completion
of that project so the drug design
process takes three weeks in our
computers so and that and that includes
the whole thing from hit all the way to
what's called a lead which is you know
from a very initial design all the way
it's something that we think is gonna
work so we're always open for more
pharma companies to partner with us so
that we can help them develop better
drugs as well you know we always though
in truth we want to have the biggest
impact we can so we really want to work
with everyone we can you know and in the
bringing in more talent you know the
thing that's most important for us is
people who
believe in a vision of a world where
these diseases are under control and
treatable and you know we don't have
these superbugs bringing epidemics right
it's about having a shared vision about
what can be done through these
technologies coupled with the skill to
make it real and I think that's what we
would be looking for yes yes and then
what would be like the simulation
environment that you're working in like
what is the software that you so these
are proprietary software that you guys
me that that we that we build yeah cool
so so these are all proprietary software
they build from a open source software
called Osprey that we helped develop as
academics okay so for instance I have
publications using Ospreys my
co-founders developed Osprey and this
was all developed so we all come from
the same lab which was Bruce Donald's
lab at Duke University we are spinning
out of that lab and in that lab they
developed Osprey which is an open-source
version of this code and what we did is
we introduced new features redesigned
pretty much everything from scratch made
it about a million times faster and you
know beyond that also introduced some
new things that were required to make it
in a farm context something that would
be successful in a form of context and
you know just continue to build can you
know the technology we have a belief
that we're great today but you know
these diseases are a huge challenge and
you have to continue pushing the
technology so that's an area that we're
all very dedicated to it's continuously
building the technology to solve these
problems I'm excited to see where
simulation software can help us not only
with like digital twins of the body and
being able to run calculations of
preventing disease pathology this type
of stuff but also doing things like
making digital terms of the planet and
simulating the evolution of our whole
species all these types of things
simulation of virus are very fascinating
I'm glad you guys are leveraging them
for the
Marcel thank you very much for thank you
really appreciate you so much thank you
we would greatly appreciate everyone and
give us your thoughts of the comments
blown up so thank you very much for
tuning in also do check out the links in
the bio below Gavin LAN design bio
design also definitely check out the
links to indie bio as well check out the
links the simulations will support these
artists ease entrepreneur Z scientists
these leaders in our communities support
them help them grow and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dream
since the world thanks for tuning in
we'll see you soon
peace